in unserem nachbarland polen ist gerade
ordentlich was los hunderttausende
demonstrieren und fordern sogar den
rücktritt der regierung auslöser ist
eine massive verschärfung des
abtreibungsrechts ja in polen können
frauen bald nur noch nach einer
vergewaltigung legal abtreiben oder wenn
ihr leben unmittelbar bedroht ist so hat
das polnische verfassungsgericht
entschieden ganz im sinne von jaroslaw
kaczynski
vize-premier und kopf der regierenden
partei mitten in der eu wird abtreibung
quasi illegal was unter anderem wegen
die un frauen rechts konvention verstößt
kaczynski hatte aber schlicht kein
interesse
frauenrechte zu verteidigen wir müssen
vor allem unsere polnischen kirchen
verteidigen
wir müssen sie um jeden preis verteilt
ich rufe alle peace mitglieder auf und
alle unsere unterstützer die kirche zu
verteidigen
wenn das nur ich oder seht ja wirklich
aus wie eine böse bauchrednerpuppe ich
meinen so ein schwangerschaftsabbruch
ist eine total intime und schwerwiegende
entscheidung die nur von frauen
getroffen werden kann und sicher nicht
von der partei
möglicherweise haben sich die pizza sagt
man das so also die leute von der partei
da aber auch ein bisschen verrechnet
seit dem urteil sind die in umfragen um
10 prozent abgesackt wenn zwei drittel
der polen sind eindeutig gegen die
verschärfung des abtreibungsrechts
kaczynski ist halt mit hilfe der
katholischen kirche ins amt gekommen
damals und denkt wohl eher schuldet den
was die kirche in polen sieht europa
jetzt immer mehr als bedrohung
die homo-ehe in irland die verurteilung
von pädophilen priestern gesetze gegen
häusliche gewalt so was gefällt der
kirche hier überhaupt nicht natürlich
nicht sehr klar in polen versuchen piss
partei und kirche seit jahren den roll
back also zurück zum frauenbild der
frühen fünfziger jetzt auch noch
sekundiert von gerichten seit die
richter in polen vom parlament
eingesetzt werden indem die pis partei
die absolute mehrheit hat hier zitat des
aktuellen des bildungsministers panik
frauen hätten die funktion der schaffung
des heimischen kaminfeuer
die aufgabe viele kinder zu gebären
zitat ende guck mal
auch bildungsminister können doch sein
für schwangerschafts abbrüche müssen
sich jetzt polnische frauen immer öfter
den sogenannten engel machern
anvertrauen oder ins ausland fahren zum
beispiel nach deutschland wo abtreibung
übrigens auch eine straftat ist die nur
in den ersten zwölf wochen nicht
bestraft wird und auch bei uns gibt es
immer mehr vor allem ländliche regionen
wo keine klinik kein arzt mehr einen
abbruch durchführt das betrifft zum
beispiel den süden baden württembergs
ganz niederbayern und die komplette
oberpfalz von der stadt passau mal ganz
zu schweigen
hier dürfen mediziner gar keine abbrüche
durchführen ein stadtratsbeschluss
verbietet es ihnen die gesetzeslage
lässt eine solche politische vorgabe
einer kommune zu
auch so das geht ja dann können wir
wegen polen nicht nur die nase rümpfen
schade niemand sollte sich diese extrem
schwere entscheidung zu leicht machen
ohne beratung geht es natürlich nicht
aber den frauen die sich dann
entschieden haben muss doch geholfen
werden in manchen gegenden in
deutschland helfen tatsächlich nur noch
eigentlich pensionierte gynäkologen das
kanns doch wirklich nicht sein
und was bitte ist aber denen in passau
los wo kultur und lebenslust
zusammenfließen
besuchen sie die veste oberhaus den
residenzplatz mit wittelsbacher brunnen
oder das legendäre 3 flüsse und seien
sie jeden zweiten samstag live dabei
wenn vor dem alten rathaus wieder eine
rothaarige als hexe verbrannt wird
passau wo das mittelalter niemals
aufgehört hat
klingt ein land mir mal angucken so und
wo wir gerade beim thema frauen sind was
ist eigentlich aus franziska giffey ist
neuer frauenquote für die vorstände von
dax-unternehmen geworden vereinfacht
gesagt nichts der gesetzentwurf wird
aktuell ausgebremst von
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
warum dazu begrüße ich jetzt sebastian
pufpaff er ist frauenbeauftragte im
wirtschaftsministerium
woran hängt es denn gut also an mir
schon mal nicht aber liebe frau welke
genauso lauert auch nicht hinter jeder
ecke die böse macho mafia
was stimmt im moment sind deutsche
vorstände noch immer zu über 90 prozent
männlich daher der alte witz deutscher
vorstand kann spuren von nüssen
enthalten
na ja gut aber unser herr altmaier hat
ja grundsätzlich nichts gegen doppel
x-chromosomen träger innen
wir waren nur von noch mehr bürokratie
seit 2016 drücken wir jetzt den
unternehmen diesen komischen zielwert
auf ja genau und das läuft ja echt super
die unternehmen hatten die vorgabe einen
zielwert anzugeben um wie viel prozent
sich die frauenquote erhöhen sollte in
den vorständen knapp 70 prozent der
unternehmen haben die zielgröße 0
angegeben
und das ist absolut richtig dass ich mir
ein ziel setzte was ich auch erreichen
kann wenn ich mich richtig reinhängen
zielgröße 0
das schafft man realistisch bleiben sie
stritten jagt jetzt auch nicht nur rosen
größe 36
[Gelächter]
interessant ist ja womit ihr haus die
ablehnung der quoten idee begründet hier
echtes zitat aus einer internen mail
gerade mit blick auf corona sollte die
regierung nur im koalitionsvertrag
festgelegte gesetzliche änderungen
vornehmen und auf andere verzichten
verstehe ich das richtig abrufbar mehr
frauen im vorstand sind in diesen
schwierigen zeiten eine zu große
belastung für die firmen ja kommen sie
können ja nicht die augen vor der
realität verschließen
wir haben corona klimawandel trump und
jetzt auch noch mehr
frauen irgendwann ist auch mal schluss
da kommt ein unternehmen auch ganz
schnell ans östrogen limit also von der
belastungsgrenze her ein glück plant
diese ihre gefährlich auch die männer
aussehen vorstellen rauszuwerfen ihre
komische quote geht ja nur wenn einer in
rente geht oder stirbt ich kenne ja
chefetagen wenn da ein abbild also weg
kompostiert wien lässt er dann einfach
mal sitzen
nach dem motto riecht zwar streng ist
aber immer noch besser als eine frau
studien beweisen unternehmen mit mehr
frauen in der führung sind innovativer
langfristig erfolgreicher unpassende auf
haben eine um 14 prozent geringere
wahrscheinlichkeit in betrugsfälle
verwickelt zu werden ja richtig richtig
richtig richtig frauen haben leider so
gar keine kriminelle energie schade sehr
schade
wo wäre denn zb volkswagen ohne ich
nenne das jetzt mal diese maskuline
kreativität im umgang mit den
abgaswerten wo wir denn herr wilke
wo wären die wo wären ich weiß nicht ich
weiß es nicht ich weiß nicht wie man
selbst in den usa ist der frauenanteil
in den topetagen inzwischen bei 28,6
prozent großbritannien fast 25 prozent
in deutschland liegen wir bei 10 ja weil
wir deutsch noch an das leistungsprinzip
glauben und zehn prozent spiegelt das
leistungsvermögen von frauen wieder das
liegt bei ungefähr zehn prozent von dem
der männer ja weibliche vorstände klingt
immer gut wenn man science fiction mag
aber da gibt es halt auch sehr
unangenehme nebenwirkungen bin der
meinung dass eine frau in
führungspositionen doch einen haushalt
gar nicht mehr verkraften kann
und das kann doch keiner wollen so schön
das auch ist ja wenn meine frau
vorstandsvorsitzende bei bayer
leverkusen ist wenn aber dafür die küche
aus wie sau das ist also da ist nun
wirklich kein mitgeholfen
also ihr ministerium wird das gesetz
weiter ausbremsen
gegenfrage wie viele frauen moderieren
denn insgesamt die heute-show sebastian
buchbar
ja it-service beweise sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung